he and new content are the currency of
choice for an emerging elite social
class according to information we
columnist Richard Florida he discussed
his new book the rise of the creative
class at a meeting of the young
entrepreneurs organization it's about an
hour and 25 minutes good morning good
morning in a week good morning my planet
this morning to welcome you to the
eleven o'clock session at the Friday and
on Friday at the University in here in
DC this morning I'm thrilled to be
introducing Richard Florida he has
recently been highlighted in the latest
national commission on entrepreneurship
sieve newsletter for his authorship of
his new book the rise of the creative
class the book gives us a provocative
new way to think about why we live as we
do today and where we might be headed
and the topic impact both our personal
and professional life so it's just with
great pleasure that I introduce this
morning Richard Florida
hey thank thank you Pamela it's a
pleasure to be with you guys here this
morning I think we're okay I don't know
I figured I'll talk for about 45 minutes
about the themes in this book and
hopefully you guys will be armed with
questions so we can fill up the other 45
minutes I want to thank I want to thank
the young entrepreneurs organization for
inviting me it's really a pleasure to be
with all of you folks who are building
and making such important contributions
to our economy I guess I want to try to
talk about the themes in my book the
rise of the creative class in light of
the kinds of things that you do and the
kinds of things that quite dear friend
Carl Schramm talked about this morning
and I want to make two main points
before I start on that what you do is
entrepreneurs is much more I think Carl
really echoed this is much more than an
economic or business process that that
in my view and I think I think when you
think about it particularly being
younger entrepreneurs what we do is
bound up with a much broader shift in
the nature of our society in what we
want out of our lives and the kinds of
lifestyles we want to leave it's not
just about money and I think too many
people have put too much emphasis
particularly now we can see some of the
downsides of that but it's not just
about money but it's about a whole set
of social and cultural and lifestyle
changes and what we as individuals
really want out of life and the second
point I want to make just just to
preface my remarks is is that
entrepreneurship doesn't take place in a
vacuum that what you do is embedded and
in mesh and a whole set of sultry social
and cultural and economic forces and
that what incentivizes entrepreneurs is
a supportive and Carl said this very
nicely ecosystem or a habitat and those
are two things I really want to
emphasize in my remarks about creativity
in the rise of the creative class what
when I say that entrepreneurship is is
bound up in this broader shift in the
way we live and work today let me give
you some illustrations and to consider
the magnitude of the shift
from when I was a boy in the 1950s and
1960s to now in this current decade when
I was young entrepreneurship was
something businessmen did and if you
went to a group like this as you all
know it would be predominantly if not
exclusively male and it was something
that was associated typically when I was
young with older people and in our
society it was not necesarily viewed as
something good people sometimes in the
1960s looked down upon entrepreneurs now
my students at Carnegie Mellon and
students and young people I talk about
all over the country view
entrepreneurship not only is something
good but something that they want out of
their lives not just as a way to make
money and feed their families and put
food on the table but as a way to
express themselves and validate their
identities as creative and talented
people in the 1960's and 1970's
entrepreneurship was not embraced by our
popular culture today it's embraced and
celebrated regardless of the downturn in
the stock market and regardless of what
Carl mentioned about this mounting sure
there's anti-capitalist feeling but
entrepreneurship is embraced and
celebrated in our culture in fact I
would argue to you that what you are
doing is entrepreneurs is leading a
broad social movement but this is much
more than simply an economic or business
phenomenon but it is part of a broad
social movement in our society
redefining the way we as individuals as
I said live and work consider the
following more than sixty percent of
young people between the ages of 14 and
19 an almost an equal amount of young
adults between 21 and 30 years of age
say they want to start a business and be
entrepreneurs more than almost
two-thirds of young people say one of
their life goals is to start their own
business and to become entrepreneurs but
according to another survey more than a
quarter of recent college graduates said
that they want to start an
entrepreneurial business in there in
their first ten years of work compared
to just eleven percent of graduates
before the year nineteen seventy one
and a roughly five percent of all
Americans are involved in an
entrepreneurial enterprise at any given
time in history but I just want to
illustrate this with a quote from my
research that I think illustrates this
this quote comes from a young woman in
Pittsburgh delightful young woman who
I've gotten a chance to spend more time
after I've interviewed her talking about
her life growing up in Pittsburgh and
her aspirations for her future and she
gets she's about 27 years of age now I
think she gave me this quote when she
was about 24 talking about growing up in
Pittsburgh the kind of condition she
grew up in in her aspirations for a
future life me I always felt like the
weirdo maybe some of you felt that way I
can only imagine the number of times it
was said to me just do it that way
because that's the way it's done I
always felt a sense that to do or be
anything outside of the realm of normal
was different or wrong I wish I had a
dime for the number of times I was
encouraged to get a real job you're seen
as a weirdo if you want to take the risk
to see and build something different I
knew I always wanted to create things
for myself but I didn't know how to do
it now I finally realize what i am what
i want to do to build these things it's
not weird it's actually called something
it's called entrepreneurship of an
entrepreneur and now this young woman is
actually engaged in two very interesting
fledgling entrepreneurial enterprises
one in the retail area and one in the
consulting area so after a long period
of trying to hook herself up with
institutions and even high-tech
companies she's doing it for herself
well in this in this book project the
rise of the creative class for the past
several years I've been trying to
understand the way we as people navigate
the world in which we live and and I
think the book comes to some interesting
and sometimes provocative conclusions
and the time we have today I'd like to
share some of those with you and I think
there are three major points three or
four major points in the book and let me
try to run through them as best I can
putting my notes aside
the first is that creativity not
technology not innovation not knowledge
not research and development that
creativity broadly construed is the
source of economic wealth and that what
you as entrepreneurs are our creative
people now think back to the way
economies used to grow three or four
hundred years ago the way an economy
grew is you were near a nice Riverways
or nice transportation routes you had
fertile soil and you grew things oh
about 150 years ago or a hundred with
the great break surges of places like
Pittsburgh and Buffalo in Cleveland the
way an economy grew is you had access to
raw an abundance of raw materials and
and sometimes umass that together with
physical labor in Pittsburgh we had a
handy metric to gauge our project
man-hours per ton of steel produced a
physical labor driven economy but as you
know in all of your fields of business
those are no longer a distinctive
competitive advantages access to raw
materials access to physical labor large
ill manufacturing plants are no longer
competitive advantage is because you can
do for a nation or community because you
can do that kind of thing anywhere the
Japanese taught us that trick that would
very little in way of raw materials and
and even with constrained labor you
could be very successful in
manufacturing businesses well what's
left what's left is knowledge and
intelligence and human creativity the
only real competitive differentiator the
advanced industrial nations or the
advanced industrial regions have is the
knowledge and intelligence of our people
every thing we do every service we
purchase every good we buy increasingly
has creative content it's take my
favorite crop my eyeglasses my dad
worked in a factory all of his life he'd
keep he was born in 1921 raised in North
New Jersey had to leave school at age 13
to help support his family went to work
in an eyeglass factory one of the things
my dad taught me at a very early age as
he worked his way up from from someone
who worked at the at the factory bench
to a foreman
manager of the plan and sometimes as a
young boy you probably did this with
your moms are dead I tug on his pants
leg and say dad would you take me where
you work would you take me to the
factory and on some Saturdays he would
relent and he'd take me down to the
factory when you drive down mccarter
highway in New Jersey if you know where
that is into the factory in Newark New
Jersey and he'd point out to meet say
Richard it's not the machine it's not
the technology it's not this wonderful
factory building the key to
understanding this Factory is the
knowledge and intelligence and
creativity of the men who work in this
factory so anyway back to my dad's
product the eyeglass my dad made
eyeglasses big plastic clunkers two
slabs of glass for lenses and we use
them to see better I actually wore
glasses at age two so I benefited from
the fact that my dad worked in an
eyeglass factory well I'm not going to
tell you what these costs but they
certainly cost a lot more than the
fifteen dollars or whatever the material
content we buy eyeglasses for their
creative content anybody see the Wall
Street Journal story on the trophy stove
I was rolling on the floor here the
story was on what you want in your new
renovated houses of course the trophy
stove and here were two people about our
age sitting behind this blue Viking like
stove with a grounded countertop with
the takeout food on top of it that stove
was not being bought at four or five or
ten thousand dollars to cook any the
hundred-thousand-dollar fantasy kitchen
which we use once a month what I like to
talk about my favorite accoutrement
kitchen are the all clad pots the
wonderful hanging all clad pods above my
stove I call them my giant charm
bracelet which i use perhaps once a
month when I decide to make some
experiential kind of cuisine meal but
everything whether we went to Equinix a
chef gray hosted us last night some of
the speakers we're not purchasing food
from chef gray we're purchasing the
experience of eating in his very
creative restaurant so increasingly
every product we buy not just
semiconductor chips and software and
biotech in robotics and this high-tech
stuff everything we buy is is
increasingly value
for its creative content so that's point
number one creativity is the cornerstone
of economic advantage and let me break
it down just one more level in my work I
argue that there are three kinds of
creativity and I believe that most
people have argued in terms of two kinds
in the past the first kind of creativity
is technological creativity the ability
to invent to innovate to create new
technologies new products new ways of
doing business incredibly important the
second kind of creativity is the kind of
creativity all of you represent economic
creativity entrepreneurship the ability
to invent not only the technologies but
to connect those technologies to solid
and successful business models the
ability to commercialize those
technologies and build successful new
firms successful in businesses and in
some cases whole new industries in ways
of doing business and the first two
kinds of creativity have been well
documented economist from Karl Marx to
Joseph Schumpeter and in the modern day
many people have studied the
intersection of technological change and
economic creativity and said those were
the lifeblood of economic growth but I
think their views a little bit limited
and I think my experience eating at
equinox last night which chef grain and
hopefully he'll be presenting to you
today as well shows the limit there's a
third kind of creativity which is
critically important to this age
artistic cultural entertainment design
architectural creativity all of the
stuff we used to put over in this box
called the arts and culture and in my
book I argue that for a nation to be
competitive for a region to be
competitive for a city to be competitive
for you to have the kind of habitat or
ecosystem you need to be successful all
three kinds of creativity need to be in
place not just the first two part of my
consideration comes from my own
experience in Pittsburgh
I moved to Pittsburgh in 1987 to take a
position at Carnegie Mellon University
to help build Pittsburgh's presence in
high technology enabled growth well you
might not know this but pittsburgh has
an inordinate amount of high-technology
assets panel and I were talking she
worked at Microsoft the director of
research at Microsoft is Rick Rashid a
colleague of mine at Carnegie Mellon who
left Carnegie Mellon to go to Microsoft
Carnegie Mellon is one of the main
sources of technical talent high-end
technical talent at Microsoft Vinod
Khosla one of those what did they call
them V Niall venture capitalist this
morning Forbes magazine called him the
leading venture capitalists in the world
Carnegie Mellon alumnus two of the
founders of Sun Microsystems Carnegie
Mellon alums but when this came home to
me was the case of a company you might
all have heard of her use called light
coast lake house was a spin-off of our
University we created the company we
built the show we put them in a lovely
building down the road from the
University and the company was going
like gangbusters I go off the sabbatical
leave at Harvard for two years in one
morning I opened the Boston Globe and
the boston globe story reports lycos
moves to boston why would like how
spawned from the technology at carnegie
mellon from a faculty member at carnegie
mellon with tight relationships to the
University move from Pittsburgh to
Boston when i called my friends at
Carnegie Mellon when i call the folks at
lake us when I put my students on the
case a simple answer came back Boston
had the ecosystem the ready supply of
creative talent across all domains that
could be quickly mobilized to build lake
house into a vibrant business and some
of that habitat was lacking in my
hometown of Pittsburgh light bulb went
off in my head we need to better
understand the way people make choices
and where they want to live well
creativity is the source of economic
growth point one in its multi dimension
point number two where does this
creativity come from well you can't dig
creativity out of the ground doesn't
come in a well you can't find it in a
mind you can't create it in a factory
creativity is different from all those
other economic assets not only is it an
intangible but it comes from these funny
things called human beings
creativity is embedded and embodied in
human beings and human beings differ
from every other kind of economic asset
because we're fickle and we're finicky
and we can choose where we want to be
and we can choose who we want to work
for so in this sense people human beings
human creativity has become the
predominant and pre ordinate factor of
production and instead of people chasing
jobs increasingly companies are finding
that they have to go with a talented and
creative people in this great reversal
well maybe you don't believe me but
maybe that I can give you an example of
someone you might believe two years ago
I was invited to speak in in this great
city of Washington DC before the
National Governors Association of course
I'm always honored to speak in front of
the 50 governors but the real reason I
went is governor Ventura was going to be
there and my students said could we get
his autograph we'd like to have governor
of course I couldn't get near the guy
his entourage is so big but before me
speaking to the group of Governors was
Carly Fiorina the CEO and chairperson of
HP and she said something that I really
I took great stock from she said
governor's keep your tax incentives keep
your financial incentive packages we
don't need the brand new bright new
highway interchange we don't even need
that great stadium that you want to
build for us we go where the highly
skilled and creative people are end of
story we make our location decision
whether it's for a research and
development unit whether it's for a
manufacturing plant whether it's for an
office function by where we can mobilize
highly skilled and creative people so
for those of you interested in national
competitiveness or regional
competitiveness what I submit is that
the future of region states and nations
will be shaped far more by the
distribution of highly skilled and
creative people then it will be that by
the distribution of firms and think
about the u.s. remarkable
competitiveness come back of the of the
1990s into this decade fueled by our
ability to attract the best and the
brightest people from around the world
according to my colleague Annalee
saxenian studies of Silicon Valley more
than
third of all new businesses started in
the valley over the 1990s were started
by immigrant entrepreneurs what a
remarkable story the United States
economic competitiveness rebound fueled
by our ability to attract the best in
the brightest now in my book I try to
document the extent of this human
creativity and I tried a document and
put some numbers to the number of people
engaged in creative work in the book I
document the rise of a new class we are
all members of this new class
entrepreneurs venture capitalist
research and development people
scientists and engineers infotech
biotech robotics musicians novelist
painters entertainers and creative
professionals in various fields from
finance to health care 38 million
members of the American workforce that's
a workforce of 130 million that's nearly
a third of the entire workforce our
numbers the creative class although we
don't think of ourselves as a class are
bigger in absolute terms and in
percentage terms than the industrial
working class we are bigger in numbers
and percent in the industrial working
class and our group of people the
creative class entrepreneurs
technologists musicians artists poets
and creative professionals has grown
from less than five percent of the
workforce in 1900 less than ten percent
of the workforce in 1950 only fifteen
percent of the workforce in 1980 our
numbers have doubled between 1980 and
the year 2000 why because creativity has
become the defining factor in the
economic competitiveness game well the
rise of creativity as an economic force
and the rise of human beings as the
factor of production in the rise of this
new class these are the factors that are
reshaping our lives look around at the
composition of this room look around at
the demography of this room look around
at the way you're dressed think of the
way you spend your days think of the way
you use your time think of the way you
recreate and engage in active outdoor
recreation think of the things you like
to javis and the interest you have and
then think about your parents
box and think about your grandparents
lives could there be a more remarkable
shift in every facet of our lives these
are not disconnected lifestyle things
this isn't just the result as David
Brooks as of a bohemian buchwald
lifestyle all of these changes in the
way we live and work are rooted in one
fundamental fact that we are called upon
to could participate in the economy
through our human creativity where our
minds have become the means of
production where our very minds have
become the means of production now I
could well this is a very long book I
could spend days in here and I know you
have many questions let me give you two
illustrations of the way the rise of the
creative economy and the rise of
creative class are reshaping the way we
work in the way we live let me first
start with the workplace well as you can
guess being a professor in a public
policy school I'm engaged in certain
public policy debates I love to come to
Washington one of the places I don't
like to go so much in my dear state
lovely Commonwealth of Pennsylvania is
harrisburg but occasionally I have to
make the pilgrimage to Harrisburg
because i'm a member of something called
the team pennsylvania board of directors
which is our governor's economic
development kitchen cabinet so we
assemble in the governor's mansion very
staid place everybody you know I have to
wear the red tie with the blue suit just
to fit in and everybody comes down and
makes the pilgrimage once every quarter
to meet with our governor and talk about
the we don't really talk they talk at us
but the talk about the pressing issues
facing our Commonwealth so one day I
walk in and everybody's looking very
straight very concerned and our
Secretary of Labor and Industry jolts
into the room large man my height and
probably 100 pounds heavier than me a
giant of a man jolts into the room he
bangs very loudly on the table he's very
concerned governor CEOs Richard you know
hello
I'm the only non CEO there we're very
concerned about the future of our
Commonwealth a crisis grips the great
state of Pennsylvania you see all of the
heavy manufacturing hard-working welders
pipefitters carpenters and machinists
they're retiring and the crisis in our
state is that none of these young people
none of these young people want to
follow in their footsteps and take their
jobs we have shortages in critical
skills whether that be welding or pipe
fitting or machine tool making in our
Commonwealth it threatens our
manufacturing base now where are these
young people going in this terrible
crisis and what worsens it all of these
young people are going to cosmetology
school and wanting to work in the hair
salon governor I submit to you that I'm
going to go to every high school in this
great state and I'm going to talk to the
guidance counselor's and I'm going to
tell them to redirect those people's
human energy and tell them that they
should not be going to work in hair
salon that what they should be doing is
going for the high paying job and the
median to a factory and I'm like whoa
big crisis right our state is going to
hell in a handbasket everybody wants to
cut hair for a living so I go back to my
office to Carnegie Mellon as I often do
and I posed the question to the students
in my in my seminar in economic
development guys what would you do if
you had two choices open to you going to
work in the machine tool factory at
twenty-five or thirty dollars an hour
with a job for life that would be quite
secure with excellent health benefits
and all other sorts of things are going
to work in a hair salon at twelve bucks
an hour as an apprentice hair cutter in
a very temporary phase with no job
security and very little in the way of
benefits what we do choose and after
pondering it for about 30 seconds they
started to shoot back Oh reg that's easy
we go to work in a hair salon
we get to be ourselves we get to set our
own hours we get to develop all of these
creative styles we learn things
constantly our clients would be nice and
they would be engaging and we develop
relationships we wouldn't have to punch
a clock there be no boss lording over us
and then came the punch line and if we
were really successful we get to open
our own hair salon if we learn the tools
of our trade and we built the client
base we could be entrepreneurs out on
our own and that's what the Secretary of
Labor and Industry missed he missed the
fact that people increasingly in this
day and age where they have choices and
where knowledge and capabilities and
skills and the means of production where
they have the choice to be able to cast
out of the room will go out on MC we had
another big misunderstanding in the 80s
we thought of course companies were
disloyal and push some of their staff
out of work but you know what
increasingly people don't want those
jobs they don't want to work for life in
the same company as my father did they
want to make their own way and they know
and we know that just like entrepreneurs
increasingly every person is acting as
an entrepreneur whether they're an
artist or musician or an entertainer or
a chef or an independent consultant
because we want to take control of our
own lives and we want to use our human
creativity to further our own goals and
as well one of the benefits of being a
professor occasionally when you're not
out speaking all over the country all
the time is you can read things so in
the course of writing this book I got to
read the entire literature on creativity
led by psychologists and there's one
resounding fact that comes back from
that literature and I think it's
important for me to share with you and
hopefully you can gain something from
Mike my summarization of these of this
literature literature says
overwhelmingly creativity is
intrinsically motivated it comes from
within and I think entrepreneurship is
the same thing the zeal the drive to be
an economically a technologically
artistically creative people
come from the outside it cannot be
motivated by intrinsic reward you cannot
pay people more to become an
entrepreneur or a great musician or a
great artist it comes from within to
raise the Amma Beal the leading student
of creativity at Harvard says creativity
is an intrinsic process using extrinsic
rewards to try to motivate creativity is
counterproductive or as Peter Drucker
said at the height of the so-called
internet new economy boom in the year
2000 bribing the knowledge workers on
which these industries depend will not
work in a sense what people want in
their work and this is borne out by the
survey data I've looked at our challenge
responsibility to work out the ability
to work on great things the ability to
be themselves realize their dreams Bay's
pay comes in fourth or fifth and you
know where the munch vaulted stock
options come in anywhere between fifty
and seventy fifth see I think in the 90s
we made a big mistake I'm just going to
submit this to you and you take away
from it what you will I think we
believed that people were motivated by
this ability to get rich quick and
certainly some people were and we saw
some of the shenanigans that some of
these big companies have led us to but
creativity is not greed driven
creativity is intrinsically driven and I
believe that in this age of the year
2000 and the new decade and the new
millennium with the events the recession
and the stock market tumbling in 911
which anniversary is coming up that
we're going to look deep down inside
ourselves and say what is powering this
economy is the flourishing of the
creative spirit and certainly people
need to make enough money to live and
feed their families and certainly people
need to be rewarded by their creative
and entrepreneurial acts but this greed
powered economy isn't sufficient and
it's going to lead us into the wrong
turns and what we need to do in the
future is to invest as individuals as
company leaders as public citizens in
make sure the creativity of all not just
the venture capitalists not just a
successful entrepreneur that the artist
and the chef and the entertainer and
more than that that the little kid
growing up in a disadvantage neighbor
doing his hip hop poetry has an outlet
for that creativity because lord knows
if we look at the US economy and we look
at where our entertainment goods come
from where arts come from where our
music come from it doesn't come
typically from the neighborhoods even
that I grew up in it comes from the most
disadvantaged the most impacted
neighborhoods in our society one of the
great challenges in this society is to
tap in an entrepreneurial way that
Fountainhead of creativity when I talk
and crawl mention these studies when I
talk to kids in low-income neighborhoods
in places like Pittsburgh or
Philadelphia or Washington DC they don't
want to go to work for some faceless
corporation they want to make it on
their own the entrepreneurial energy in
these communities based on people's
creativity is boundless and that's an
important challenge for society well I
want to tell you about one other aspect
of my work and I want to tell you about
my work on the nature of community in
place it's a little bit off your subject
but I want to share it with you because
I think you might benefit from some of
it one of the arguments in my book is
that with the demise of the large
corporation you see my dad worked for
the same company for life and my mom and
dad lived in the same house all of their
life with the demise of the large
company we no longer take our identity
from a business corporation we take our
identity from two places as human being
the skills and capabilities and
intelligence and creativity we have and
the places we live now think about it 20
years ago when you got on a plane the
first question person would ask is who
do you work for my father's age you know
I work for General Motors I work for
Ford I work for IBM I work for General
Electric and Anna company could
literally move you around as well and
you pack up the family and go now when
you get on the plane of course what do
people ask you where do you live and you
know what place has a status implication
and I love this when I lived in
Manhattan you know somebody asked me
where do you live and i gloat sit on the
plane and I said I live in I didn't say
New York I live in Manhattan and then
when i moved to boston i was i was very
happy to say i live in boston except
when i went to new york i would say i
live in boston
and when people ask me where do you live
now I say I teach at Carnegie Mellon and
I live in Pittsburgh now that that's
that I loved hits burg it's a wonderful
city it's a fantastic City but it shows
you how place has become a status good
and we purchase place for a lot of
reasons including as a status good but
place is more important than this here's
what I'd submit that place in community
geographic region has replaced the
corporation as the fundamental economic
building block of the creative age I
know that sounds extreme but bear with
me what is a corporation to a large
corporation do well it returns dividends
to the stockholders hopefully it
generates wealth it pays incomes it pays
benefits it builds up a vase of salary
successful employees creates wealth but
how does it do that does that for a very
simple process of matching a human being
to a task to be done matching a human
being to attach to be done and in the
great Golden Age of the organization man
perhaps for 1922 1970 it was very
effective at doing that but something
happened in the past 30 years that
system broke down average went to stay
in a job for the average American is
three years for an American under under
30 is one year how do you match these
people to a job to be done what was
Carly Fiorina talking about what does
the Lycos example illustrate physical
place geographic place is the mechanism
to do that for a company it allows that
company it allows your company to be in
a habitat with a large pool of talented
and creative people in the niche you
need to be in and for an individual and
what we found in our focus groups and
interviews with individuals making
location choices people were not
selecting places based on a job they
were selecting places based on the
opportunity to have lots of jobs a thick
labor market a thick labor pool for
companies and a thick labor market for
people so place I would submit has
become a fundamental economic building
block of this new age now we know that
creativity is an important source of
wealth we know that creative creativity
comes from people and we know that place
is an important building block but
there's one question we haven't answered
and believe it or not in my field of
regional economic development a
hundred-year-old field no one asks the
most basic
simple question until the morning I woke
up and open that paper about lycos why
in the heck do we choose the locations
that we do my field had focused for
nearly a hundred years on why companies
choose the locations they do not why
people choose the locations they do and
so that's that's the task that's the
journey that's what I set out to try to
solve let me tell you of course I said
the first thing people no longer move
just for a job they move for abundant
Economic Opportunity thick labor markets
but what else determines the kind of
places people want to live and work
three or four things very quickly first
thing creative people need to be in a
creative environment creative people
want the kind of excitement that you
feel in in and around a place like
Washington DC last night when I walked
up to dupont circle and over to
connecticut took the cab over to adams
morgan you can just feel the human
energy on these streets people want to
be at a broadly creative environment you
know what creative people have always
lived in creative environment and I
don't mean that everybody's going to
live in Adams Morgan or everybody's
going to live in Greenwich Village or
everybody's going to live in soma but if
you look at the cities and regions in
growth areas of the country they all
have these kinds of districts even if
people live out in the suburbs and
commute in whenever they need to get
that ingestion of creative particularly
young people prefer these places in
Seattle Microsoft has now set up a bus
to bus its people who want to live in
downtown Seattle out to the campus but
people need this creative environment
and it's not just ball fields and
Symphony halls and big cultural
institutions it's this active
street-level cultural environment let me
tell you one funny thing we did I'm a
social scientist so we have to build
indicators we can't just make this up so
I'm sitting around my kitchen table one
day and I say to my students guys my PhD
students very bright people at Carnegie
Mellon much better than handy with
statistics and the computer then I'll
ever be can we make an indicator of this
creative environment can we build a
bohemian index and index of the bohemian
people who happen to live and work in a
community they're like shorts and
occupational category painters and
musicians and inter we built the
Bohemian index
this bohemian index this listing of
people who work in the bohemian arts and
culture predicts regional rates of
innovation high technology growth
entrepreneurship and overall economic
growth as good or better than any
existing factor so people want to be in
a creative and stimulating place well
one of the reviews of my book in the New
York Times this guy named rob walker
brownie said he always said the Richard
Florida has written a thoughtful and
provocative book on the nature of life
in our times and then I just waited for
the other shoe to drop right you just
wait when somebody set you up like that
and he said if Florida's creative class
is working so creatively why are we all
so bored in our work why are we instant
messaging and sending people games in a
meeting you know and playing solitaire
and I wrote him back and I said Rob you
nailed it many creative people are bored
at their work they don't have the
stimulation they need part of the
challenge in the war push is to make it
a more stimulating engaging environment
and there's a bunch of experiments silly
experiments the rock climbing wall on
the side of the building the joke call
in the fridge you know all of this silly
stuff that's gone on over the course of
the 90s much of it which is falling away
that's why people need creative
communities because the creative
community provides that ingestion of
stimulation whether it's a break for a
coffee or going out for a run at noon or
going cycling or whatever it is you do
to prepare yourself for in the words of
one of my interview subjects a second
working day so that's the nature of
changes in the workplace and the
challenge for you I would submit is not
only to think of ways to motivate your
people with money but to think of ways
to motivate your people and this is very
hard and I don't have the magic bullet
to motivate your people by acting on
their intrinsic reward structures that's
the challenge in workers what else do
people want a community people said
expressively diversity diversity was one
of the things people particularly
creative class people valued much in the
communities they selected they wanted to
see that a place had visible signs of
diversity in that community why you're
entrepreneurs your creative people you
know the answer we act on meritocratic
norms we want to know that we're going
to succeed
not based on on who we are in terms of
our gender or our physicality are an
ethnicity but based on what we have in
our heads what our capabilities and
skill sets are and this came back
resoundingly in our focus groups and
interviews you know what we had to build
some indicators so we did it again we
built indicators of interracial couples
& % non-white and we called it a melting
pot index % foreign-born had all of
these indicators of a region we're very
closely associated with a region that
would innovate spawn entrepreneurial
firms and become an high economic growth
region but there was one indicator that
really sold the book that really sold
the book inmate has made this book of
success and I need to tell you the story
behind the indicator so I come back from
Boston I take up in my office at
Carnegie Mellon I go to visit my Dean I
say how are you doing it's a great day
great to be back in Pittsburgh ask me
what i'm working on us i'm working on
the location decisions of entrepreneurs
and high technology people and people
who work in these knowledge i hadn't
come up with the idea of creativity or
creative class people who work in these
high-growth businesses people who want
to start their own businesses why do
they choose these locations that
unanswered question he said Richard you
got to go meet Gary gates he's finding
the same things you are he's finding
that what you are that people are
choosing these exciting vibrant how we
called it in those days hi amenity
places he's the big Gary's working on
the location decisions of the gay
population so what could high technology
knowledge worker people and gay people
have in common he said go visit Gary so
Gary and I sat down and I still remember
the day I put my list of the high
technology highly entrepreneurial new
form formation mecca's on the table he
put his list of the gay cities on the
table and they were the same cities the
same exact cities so we ran his measure
called the gay index against all of my
measures of high-tech roads and economic
growth and economic development and you
know what this guy index like the
Bohemian index predicted rates of
entrepreneurship and economic growth
better than all the existing indicators
why it's not because entrepreneurs are
oversampled to be gay it's not because
Bohemians start a lot of business
although I would argue where you can
have a flourishing music scene because
everything new happens in a garage right
whether it's a garage band or a garage
startup where you have the preconditions
in a
environment that supports an active
street level cultural scene you're
likely to have a very risk-taking
culture think about the Silicon Valley
out there in San Francisco not it may be
the blend what do they call it Nerdist
and that joel Kotkin calls it but it's
in this creative cauldron called the San
Francisco Bay Area it's not because of
these things automatically cause
entrepreneurship it's where culturally
interesting and innovative people will
locate it's where members of the gay
community feel comfortable those are
signaling a habitat a habitat that is
open to all kinds of risk-taking
entrepreneurial behavior where people
can realize their dreams so those are
the factors that seem to be associated
with high rates of high technology grows
and high rates of entrepreneurship want
to just end on one one last note going
back to this thing about creativity and
greed and some of the real challenges
that face our country today you look
back at the 1990s if you really take a
long hard look back at the decade of the
1990s they look a heck of a lot like the
1920s don't that the 1990s looks a heck
of a lot like the 1920s what happened in
the 1920s in the 1990s in the 1920s we
saw the rise of whole new industries
whole new technologies one of the
greatest movement forwards in human
innovation and great entrepreneurial
fortunes Rockefellers morgan's
Carnegie's melons the rise of the great
fortunes around these all new industries
and we had lost faith in the 1920s in
any of our rules and institutions so
what did we say we'll let the market
regulate this and we put our faith in
the stock market and we said people will
be rewarded for all of these
entrepreneurial undertakings with
holdings in stock same thing in the
1990s we totally lost face the
government we totally lost faith in any
rules and regulations how are we going
to birth these new industries from
software to biotech high technology the
internet and all of the other things in
retail and all the other great walmart
and FedEx we're going to use the market
and how we're going to reward people
we're going to use stock options and
stock options can be a healthy reward
but lord knows there's been a lot of
shenanigans
and a lot of financial imaginations
around the use of these options and in
both cases we let ourselves into a
recession and hopefully not this time
into a full-scale depression but in the
1930s we entered into depression what
happened in the 1930s did we go back to
the 1880s you know in nineteen hundred
forty percent of the population worked
in agriculture by nineteen forty forty
percent of the working population worked
in industry now in the 1930s we've
developed new ways of investing in our
country which leveraged and accentuated
and reinforced the industrial and
organizational economy we were then
building people sometimes say to me oh
yeah the 1990s are over everybody's
going to strap on a tie and I only wear
ties very few times in any given year
everybody's going to strap on a time go
back to work for the big corporation and
everybody's going to become conservative
again wrong-o this decade is analogous
to the 1930s and the challenge now is to
look past the mess in fact the challenge
to us as members of the creative class
38 million of us is to begin to think
about what kind of economy and society
we want to build in the future not just
an economy where a few people get ultra
mega rewarded of course there needs to
be rewards for excessively an extremely
contributed creative activity but we
need to be think about a system where
the young hip hop poet and the aspiring
chefs and the musician and the designer
and the urban designer and the architect
as well as the new inventor of some
semiconductor chip or biotechnology
process or robotic gizmo gets rewarded
that's our challenge and you know what
to do that we cannot just look inward at
ourselves what's the great mantra of the
creative class you know it you probably
do it oh well what I'd really like is a
new SUV no not a new SUV I want to
renovate my kitchen if I only had that
vacation to Maui wouldn't I be happy and
the people in the government they just
don't get it oh my god the mayor what
the governor he's at the lunch the
president who knows what planet he's on
the key thing though 38 million of us
the biggest most economically vibrant
educated political force far more
educated than the working class was when
they organized themselves and what is
the challenge and somebody mentioned
this should we organize the pack a good
idea we need to think about ways to
begin to mobilize ourselves to think
about ways to make our voices heard to
change this and I think the question is
not nationally the question is in our
very communities how do we harness our
energy our insights are entrepreneurial
zeal to transform these political
structures and governmental institutions
that frankly my students were in public
policy school don't want to go to work
for that's the challenge of our time how
do we turn harness this tremendous
energy this intrinsic need to be
creative this intrinsic want to be an
entrepreneur and get out of these
institutional boxes and how because we
are the successes and the role models
and the mentors how not only do we give
back but how do we open up new roadways
and pathways that the people behind us
and a scientist can participate in
thanks for listening and we have time
for plenty of questions
and I'll come down here please fire away
new all New Orleans I would say is one
of the top three culturally rich cities
in the United States we've got artists
we've got chefs Joel's the chef
musicians designers have a big Susanna
great gay population but i would say
that there's not an abundance of
opportunity and perhaps it goes back to
corruption in the city but we have a new
man things are changing but I'd like to
hear your comments folks don't know my
work has been broiled in a huge debate
in New Orleans because I rank new
Harlan's low on the Bohemian index and
New Orlean i'ts just lit up like a flame
when you call them non bohemian well in
my book I say that there are in order to
build a growth region you need three
ingredients technology talent and
tolerance most cities like my city
Pittsburgh or cities like Cleveland have
focused on the technology piece what I
find that in the true growth regions
whether that San Francisco that ranks
first on my index Austin Texas that
ranked 2nd Boston and San Diego that
ranked third or Seattle that ranks fifth
they do all three T's they invest
heavily in technology and they have
world-class world-class universities
they are actively engaged in attracting
and retaining and orienting themselves
to really harnessing talent but they're
also quite good at being open and
diverse then there are two kinds of
classes of cities that do any one or the
other to the Pittsburgh's and
Cleveland's do the first t technology
really well but do less well on talent
and less well intolerance what I would
submit is the issue in New Orleans and
if you read the thing that I wrote in
the gambit I kind of said this new
orleans has a great advantage in the
third t like miami tolerance and
diversity the key for new orleans and i
think you nailed it is to invest more in
technology to build up the university
adjusted hopefully diverse and
artistically first
hello
most of what I've accomplished lately
has been through the creativity of that
of my stack it had to kind of take
another that I've started so how do you
suggest we have only so many ways to
motivate it
these of entrepreneurs that have been
written as well as in histories of great
jazz musicians or or or any is that this
process is very intrinsic it comes from
wanting to realize a dream and of course
making money whether you're an artist or
an athlete or a chef or an entrepreneur
in any respect is a great thing but it
comes from some idea of validating
yourself ourselves that's why we do the
things we do and so I think for managing
other people that's what we have to
think about how do we allow them in
their work to validate themselves and
their own identities how do we work on
their intrinsic rewards I mean I'm going
to say silly things to you but but it's
much less expensive than all of the
other accoutrements that we thought went
around with the new economy how do we
give people a little bit of time off to
pursue things that really interest them
let me give you an example I was out
visiting in Cincinnati and cincinnati
has had a tough time attracting
african-americans it's not a place
that's viewed as all that hospitable to
african-americans and what the folks at
Procter & Gamble did when they recruit
young african-americans is they've
allowed them to form their own nonprofit
their own organization aimed at the
recruitment and attraction of other
young African Americans now that's on
the company dime and it certainly is a
cost of doing business but you want to
talk about motivating those folks to do
their work that's probably the best
marginal dollar that they could spend
because they're going to try to enact
the community which is supportive of
their interest I think those are the
kinds of things people need to do my
colleague Denise Russo I don't want to
get into a whole academic debate here
talks about the idiosyncratic deal in
other words that your deals with your
employees in the past everybody got the
same deal on the assembly line 15 bucks
an hour the same benefit package what
Denise says and I think what you all
know is that all of your creative
employees are different some are single
they need one thing you might want to
come in later some have kids we're
talking about this last night and
extending vacation by two days over the
Christmas holiday so people didn't have
to get babysitters and daycare for those
two days when their kids are home some
may be gay and and they may want the
besties partner benefits it's thinking
about each employee as an individual and
what are both they're there for
nancial means and their intrinsic
motivations i would say that we're in
the infancy of this nobody has the magic
bullet none of the management theories
have this ironed out but it's process
we're going to go through for several
decades really screwing with your whole
hear you I'm sorry go government must
really be screwing with that entire
thing of treating everybody as an
individual because one of the things I'm
finding more difficult as my company
grows is treating people as individuals
because you can't I mean it's just an
absolute nightmare I mean are there any
thoughts or anything going on with with
changing that I mean it makes it very
difficult no I think that's our
day-to-day struggle i don't i don't know
if there's any magic bullets and
certainly government policies and
programs complicate that because they
kind of tell you to treat everyone the
same and and i think i think that's a
long the transformation of governmental
institutions is a 50 year deal I mean
this is think about it every time we've
had one of these massive economic and
technological changes government doesn't
change overnight I took 50 years for us
to begin to change the governmental
institutions that we inherited from that
from the 19th century as we move into
the 20th but if government is not going
to change on its own it's going to take
your involvement in your interest to do
it some of us were at the White House
yesterday and it seems that the
administration's definition of a real
person is the working class and as you
state that well and as you state the if
the numbers are really with the creative
class and when you know I think that the
luxury tax is a great example of stupid
legislation do you see any type of real
movement and real push towards you know
I think we're the new silent majority I
mean I don't remember when people talked
about the silent majority in the 70s I
think this creative class group is the
silent majority and existing interest
groups whatever they be unionized group
special interest groups have a
stranglehold on our politics and what
I'm trying to say although i don't i
don't put out a political platform
because i don't i don't pretty supposed
to know these things but that one of the
things that's going to happen is that
this group is going to have to become
more actively involved and act actually
now i see politicians beginning to
understand you don't see them at the
national level but i'll bet in some of
you
communities you're beginning to see
political allies in Pittsburgh where I
live a place that is defined by a legacy
of machine politics we have a fantastic
new council person his name is Bill
Peduto he's organizing entrepreneurs and
artists and musicians he's organizing
students he's organizing architects he's
organizing aspects of the of the
minority community around the new
coalition which will battle the existing
special interest groups so so I think
it's happening but but it's going to
take a lot of grassroots and I don't
think it's going to happen in the White
House first I think it's going to bubble
up from local efforts and from
communities look back at history so if
you look back at history cultures are
judged by their art and creative efforts
and it seems that in the last I don't
know about 50 years hundred years that
our society has gotten away from putting
a higher value on the Arts I see artists
in New York struggling just a bit of eat
dinner and it seems like there isn't
that support what's happened in the
recent history that you think is gotten
to side away from that support let me
tell you some of the things I'm thinking
about these are very emerging thoughts
and I've certainly not bought them
through because I just wrote a book and
I'm on a book tour so this is kind of
his in Kuwait as it will get I think as
we move into this decade we're moving
into something like a new deal for the
creative age that's what we have to
think about and we have to think about
broad-based investments in creativity
the broad-based investments in higher
education broad-based investments in
entrepreneurial support broad based
investment in arts and cultural support
what has happened in our arts community
and I don't want to get into a big arch
stick here because I'm not on a student
of economic and business competitiveness
my research has been on venture capital
finance industries and entrepreneurship
all my life but drove me into this was
the thought that creativity broadly
defined helps the entrepreneurial
technologically innovative economic
growth process what what artists and
musicians typically do in our society
how do we support them we support them
through the analog of a big corporation
or big government they're attached to
these huge behemoth monolithic cultural
institutions and you know most artists
are entrepreneurs
think about it an artist I was in a band
I was going to be a musician being in a
garage band is fundamentally
quintessentially an entrepreneurial act
what a way to start to teach kids about
entrepreneurship instead of saying you
know you've got to make widgets sure
some kids want to make widgets but what
if you want to make a band show them
some structures show them some business
structures let's play this out artistic
Annie won't only the one who has the
great painting gets paid why don't we
start supporting some of these starving
artists with the equivalent of cultural
venture capital ok so you support a
thousand of them one becomes Keith
Haring why not take a royalty stream
back to your arts organization not the
whole thing one percent two percent
three percent five percent and put that
royalty stream in a banach in a fund to
support more artists what about music
people need venues they need places to
play they need places to practice they
need quiet rooms why not provide that
why not even support some artists with
the supplement not the whole gig but if
they're going to get fifty percent of
the gate and the gauge 500 bucks throw
in another 500 bucks and when you get a
band that's successful out of your
community whether it's rusted root
coming out of Pittsburgh or the violent
femmes coming out of Milwaukee or
Nirvana and the whole thing that comes
out of Seattle if they're participating
in that why not draw off the royalties
and that's what I'm talking about moving
away from the handout approach and
supporting the why not do the same thing
we did why not do the same thing with
athletes you know people who want to
engage in outdoor recreation that are
struggling so that if Lance gets this
tremendous support from the city of
austin and becomes a world-class no not
we're not going to drain all of lances
income of course not but some marginal
small percentage of that goes back into
a fund I think we've got a brick what
what these programs need is the kind of
thinking and business modeling and
structuring you have to break out of
this idea that okay well that the the
Cultural Arts Fund is going to fund the
one Keith Haring that somehow crawled up
from the you know crawled up out of his
neighborhood and made it I think that's
the way we've got to begin to think
about this
philadelphia my receptionist is that the
unions in our big old industrial city
have really limited our growth and
stymie news and I just wanted to see
what your thought was on the future
moving forward as to what you think the
future of unions hold and particularly
maybe the city of Philadelphia in areas
such as that but I love Philadelphia and
I'll be in Philadelphia on the third
doing a whole series of event so
hopefully I'll see you there I think
actually i just want to say I think
Philadelphia has made a turn much for
the better I think Philadelphia is a
place that's poised to be one of these
creative class centers what do I think
about unions I think we've got to get
beyond all of these bureaucratic
large-scale industrial institutions and
somehow we've got to make the case that
these institutional protections called
unions are no longer as relevant see I
think one thing that can happen in this
period is there can be a reaction
backward and you could start see
engineers and scientists we know some of
the artistic people have founded unions
I think it would be a mistake to move
backward to this kind of Union
environment I think the way to move
forward is to harness people's
entrepreneurial energy but we got to
collectively make the case for that or
else people in an economically insecure
time might say okay this union is going
to protect me as it did my parents and
my grandparents I think what's hurt
states like Pennsylvania our state is
this fact that we have I don't want to
suggest unions we've inherited a legacy
of these very conservative protective
institutions some of them are big
companies some of them are big unions
some of them are big foundations and I
think that what you're finding in some
of these growth regions without that
legacy is they're able to mobilize these
creative human resources but I think
we've got to make the case for them you
know what I think most people are ready
for the case certainly when I talk to my
students this kind of argument just
naturally resonates but I want to try to
get questions over here
next or the other index that you
mentioned internationally absolutely I
mean we're going to try the prop the
problem with how do you apply these
indexes internationally is that internet
and international statistic taking is
not that great but one of the things I'd
like to do and maybe we could do this
together and maybe we can do it with
some with a Global Entrepreneurship
monitor data that the Kauffman
Foundation I actually have two students
an Italian student and an Irish student
working on this how do you develop say
at the national level and we don't even
need to go to the sub-national level
because the u.s. is a big country how do
we develop indicators of cultural
creativity diversity and so on and so
forth because what we're finding of
course is that in some of these
countries and this is just from the case
study work and actually we have a little
paper written it's not quite quite right
we're finding that some countries like
Italy with tremendous creativity are
still seeing a migration of many of
their best and brightest a little bit of
a brain drain particularly to the United
States I also think that they're good
international models and the model that
I think is really fantastic is Dublin
Ireland and I think it bears really a
lot of introspection how you could take
in 20 years one of the economic back
orders of Europe and make it probably
the highest per capita income location
and they did that by doing three things
of course they did traditional company
rating right I hate to say it doesn't
fit my theory but they did go out and
raid us big companies and European big
companies they pump money into the
universities and what they did different
than Greece and Portugal and Italy and
other European countries while they were
putting the monies into the roads the
Irish were putting the money into
education and particularly higher ed and
the third thing they did which sounds
kind of silly is all this stuff on the
street level artistic and cultural front
right the tax subsidies for Bono and u2
and Van Morrison and Ron Wood so they
made Dublin a kind of creative place
across the board and I think there's a
lot of lessons for other European
nations in that I also think we could
look at the Asian in East Asian
countries and try to see what's going on
there but yet something I'd very much
like to I'd like to work on and like to
encourage all of us and think about it
you're right about cities like
Pittsburgh and Cleveland I live in
Cleveland we've lost five fortune 500
companies in the past ten years but
you're inspiring me to approach our new
mayor about
creating a more positive entrepreneurial
landscape in that city she's brand new
and ambitious could you help me do that
what will be in Cleveland will be in
Cleveland twice October and please give
me your cards will be in Cleveland
october and november isin cleveland is a
great city even though we're rivals the
Browns and the Steelers I think
Cleveland is a great city I think
Cleveland has achieved a lot and I think
what our cities have to understand
different than the New York cities like
New Orleans with the technological
resource we have I mean think about the
technology in case in the cleveland
clinic or Carnegie Mellon the University
of Pittsburgh met it's a gold mine I
mean it's like a veritable pot of gold
just stuck in front of you and what
happens of course in a place like
Cleveland or Pittsburgh this is not
meant to be critical and sometimes in my
home town you know I take it on the chin
because they say you're being critical
Cleveland Pittsburgh they don't allow
people to get validated for taking risks
and it's not just entrepreneurs I mean
one of the greatest venture capitalists
in the world David Morgenthaler there so
there have been written we have Henry
Hillman who's made a lot of investments
in startup companies in our town they
don't allow these people to validate
themselves as complete people so the
weird kid who somehow will migrate to
seattle or austin think about Steve Jobs
right think about steve jobs and steve
wozniak with hair down to their butts
beards and birkenstocks walking into the
local bank in Pittsburgh or Cleveland
they wouldn't get through the door but
there was something in the air you know
the other example is our friend Paul
Allen from Seattle and I think he bears
mentioning you know when he makes it
successfully when he becomes the third
or fourth richest man in the world what
does he invested he does a lot of
investments he helps build a sports
stadium he supports local street level
culture but his big emblematic thing is
a museum to honor Jimi Hendrix my
boyhood idol that's saying something
that there was something in the Seattle
environment that allowed Jimi Hendrix to
become quite successful in musically
successful paving the way for Paul Allen
to realize his dream I think the point
to make this simple use that cities like
Pittsburgh and Cleveland I have a tie on
I have a blue student have to loosen up
that's what I'm saying they have to
loosen up and not only risk taking is a
risk-taking economic risk taking is a
subset of all other kinds of risk cake
that's what I'm trying to say and if you
want entrepreneurship to
grow if you want people to thrive you
have to be open to whatever their life
dreams are and you know sometimes their
life dreams are bizarre like many of my
students want to be both kind of how to
have a company working on technology but
be a DJ at night and you have to allow
them to be able to do both things
there's questions in the back cover is
missing the swords creativity goes over
the last five years I've seen lots of
creative business plans and over the
last couple years we've seen a lot of
created accounting how do you know
reconcile these the differences in
between creativity and true
entrepreneurship I think I understand
I've been waiting to say this well write
an essay
okay and I don't think we're thinking
about the tweaking I think we're
thinking about okay pull back the social
movement we call entrepreneurship during
the 90s was not that people wanted to
get rich by 35 the reason they went to
entrepreneurial companies the reason so
many more people gravitated to this kind
of thing the reason kids were
gravitating to the hair salon was
cultural and social not just economic
they were places that they could realize
their dreams fulfill themselves be
themselves and so what I'm thinking is
if we act on those assets will have a
much better structure in the future and
we're going to have to limit the
excesses absolutely oh man I don't know
who to call long i'm gonna 8 60s and
early 70s i disagree with what you're
saying that we don't need a revolution I
really think that we do we celebrate the
individual in our society a very
shallowly the institution's the
government is set up its supported by
people who vote themselves benefits
you're talking about groups like what's
the retired baare who but even if were
38 million we are one-tenth one-ninth of
the population so while we celebrate the
individual is an employer I know what it
costs me to bring an employee in the
door so that I can sell them so that I
can support all the people who truly
don't produce so what you're talking
about in reality is a revolution what
you're talking about is bringing things
into line with what we say that we
celebrate and truly don't and it our
government is not structured to support
that we're clearly going to have to
overall our governmental structures and
let me tell you what I think's really
positive about this time in what what
really gives me great heartens me we're
in a pretty tough economic car I mean
people have we've wiped a lot of wealth
out of this economy but no nobody is
that negative I mean if you think about
in contrast to the 30s where people were
really down in the
Hoovervilles and and then protesting in
the streets I mean what we have is a
group of people who are really quite
optimistic really quite optimistic about
our future and and that gives me great
great hope I don't see people saying you
know the company sold me down the river
my life is miserable they what they say
is I'm gonna pick it up and I'm going to
get on with my life and often people who
are laid off site now I'm going to do
that with that I'm going to form my own
business I'm going to take
responsibility for my own life and I
think that's where we begin and I think
if we look at it like we're gonna have
to overthrow the whole thing next week
we're not going to accomplish that it's
going to take one little building block
at a time in one little example at a
time and I think it's got to occur you
know maybe it's think globally act
locally it's if our focus is on the
federal government we're going to miss
the boat I think the focus needs to be
on our local communities where we have
real leverage where an individual
entrepreneur a group of entrepreneurs a
group of people can really make their
voices heard and begin to change things
but yeah I'm going to agree with you I
mean I'm a shoe Batarian if Joseph
Schumpeter the great economist he says
every time you get these new ways of
industry formation these new different
ways of economic organizing you set in
motion a process he called it creative
destruction creative destruction you
wipe out the ol but in wiping out the
new you don't just destroy the old you
creatively destroy and you bring in a
whole new set of structures but we're in
the infancy of that process I mean we're
in the very very infancy of that process
but i think it's small one at a time
building blocks and that eventually that
will accumulate into something quite
quite different than what we have now oh
man i think from a town called Oak Ridge
Tennessee are you familiar with it
Little Bay it it's a single-purpose town
it was created by the government for the
Manhattan Project and it no one was from
that area that came from all over the
world basically for a single purpose so
and it had the highest concentration of
PhDs and it was a for a small town it
had a symphony it had an orchestra had
ballet had art museum and it is just as
you said it was a single company town in
those
energy you are a union carbide man and
you wore your three diamonds for your 30
years on your lapel since then it's kind
of lost its purpose the Cold War is over
and our population has been 27,000 in
the census of 1990 and is still 2,000 I
mean 27,000 the year 2000 what's the
town like that do well I mean there's a
big competitive disadvantage to being
small I mean in this world where you
need to offer options where people want
a lot of different things there's a big
disadvantage to being small but small
places can compete and i think i think
the places you want to look at are the
places like Santa Fe New Mexico perhaps
bigger Asheville North Carolina perhaps
bigger Athens Georgia places that are
small that have become not only places
that are technologically interesting but
they come lifestyle and artistic and
cultural Mecca and if you have that kind
of population I mean what I'd start to
do is take your city leaders to look at
some of these other places that are
small I was on the plane this is amazing
and a lot of my stuff deals with a
younger demographic were all young
entrepreneurs on the plane with this
remarkable woman who had just retired
several years ago move to jacksonville
florida lived in a golf course community
got really bored her and her husband
they went out and searched for places to
retire they look at Santa Fe they with
the Tucson they looked at Athens Georgia
they looked at Oxford Mississippi and
they looked at Asheville North Carolina
they chose Asheville North Carolina why
great culture excitement nice mountains
nearby street life great restaurants
they had a center I couldn't believe it
I had her send me email a Center for
Creative retirement where her and her
husband could do whatever weather it we
start a new business or learn sculpture
there was a center there which enabled
them in their second career to engage
their creativity so that's what I think
places like Oak Ridge need to think
about I think what we're talking about
is how do you make place is not only
places to make a living but a
destination that people really want to
be a challenge you a little bit only I'd
like to challenge you a little bit on
New Orleans because I think you factor
I'm never going to escape New Orleans I
think you missed noka New Orleans Center
for the creative arts funded by disney
and other major corporations which it
teaches every discipline of the Arts it
doesn't matter what your income level is
you're on a competitive basis to be in
the school it's one of the most
incredible things I've ever witnessed
but translating into being an
entrepreneur going from the children
that are in this school or for me for
for instance I was an apprentice when I
was 12 and I think that the most
difficult thing is taking your
entrepreneur your creativity and going
to a bank as an artist and receiving fun
in you know receiving financing I think
that's the largest challenge because
they don't see you as someone who can
manage money they see you as an artist
and I think that in our in our own
communities it's a challenge for all of
us to educate it's the big it's
awareness it's procession and aware just
maybe this isn't a challenge maybe we've
just figured out that maybe we've just
collectively figured out the recipe or
the prescription and that is the way
city set up entrepreneur like think
about it this is something the Kaufman
folks are going through they've realized
this the entrepreneurship programs are
in the business schools where's the last
place an artist going to go the last
place an artist or a chef is going to go
is into a business school they think you
know that's where all these business
people are but i think this Cole concept
of incubation of supporting of having
people you know most businesses that are
formed are more of these mom and pop you
know what we talked about at the garage
band the chef's wanting to learn how to
start and open a restaurant and this is
a completely chaotic process God God as
much as it was founded on five thousand
dollars that's the most I could get from
from any bank no one wanted to even take
a look at me and and that's really the I
think that's the deck suit because
that's the plasticity issue what in our
room in your Haluk yes collaterals your
collateral is not a bunch of machines
and a bunch of physical assets lying
here you know around on the floor so I
think that's what we're taught in this
what I call I hate this word maybe you
guys can come up with a better word new
deal for the creative age
it's not a new deal like big
institutions government programs it's
exactly that how do we create mechanisms
to funnel fun and I'm not talking about
big amounts of money how do we create
mechanisms which allowed this creative
and entrepreneurial spirit to attend in
New Orleans this would be the most
appropriate thing cuz you're not your
center of lifestyle a center of great
cooking a center of great music center
of great art why not think about that as
an entrepreneurial project for the
instead of trying to become the next
Silicon Valley I don't know if that's
your debate story Iran emeril's first
kitchen from 1993 and I would tell you
that I can only tell you that he started
his first restaurant in the low six
figures and he now runs a 45 million
dollar a year operation and do you know
that he had trouble getting financing to
start and had it had to get a backer the
most successful entrepreneur I know is
Mario Batali right my friend my best
friend from college you know what he
said every day in college when I talked
about writing books he talked about
opening a restaurant now he was in
college did college do anything to
support Mario's dream to be a chef now
he knew he needed a bachelor's degree
just to be have a bachelor's degree
every day he talked about being a chef
that he's not quite up at Emeril's level
but he has two shows on the Food Network
he has a network of restaurants in New
York City he's an entrepreneur managing
an entrepreneurial enterprise and that's
why I think it's so good to Todd gray is
talking here today but this idea that
entrepreneurship is broad and it
involves many pursuits and there are
many people who want to be involved in
this and then for the public policy
agenda how do we broaden this debate and
exactly the domains you're talking about
taking us to a global perspective you
talk about the concentration of
creativity driving businesses and people
but how does that compare to the mass
labor markets of India and China 2.5
billion people and obviously creativity
innovation exists there but you know
looking to the next eight years and with
this creativity in the labour markets
and the the economic advantage those
labor markets where's the future going
well let me say a couple things that
might be seen as provocative I think
it's great that Mexico is becoming an
industrial developed nation I'm not so
nervous as Ross Perot that there see
all of our manufacturing jobs I think
it's great that China is becoming a
participant in the world economy you
know America doesn't have to have
everything I mean we get a we have a
good life here and we don't have to have
all the manufacturing jobs I know that
something but I think it's great that
these labor markets are emerging and you
know I've done a lot of studies of the
global economy I've walked from achelous
I've walked through the factories in
Tijuana in Guadalajara you know what
they're good places to work compared to
the options that Mexican person has
their bus to work they get paid every
week they have classes in the factory
when I see the people walking around the
factory they look like they're enjoying
themselves and they're smiling sure
they're not making what an American and
sure their wages should go up but we're
not going to compete in the United
States on that basis they're going to
compete on labor and as part of their
development strategy they're going to
have to build wealth they're going to
have to build wealth by doing these
simple task but the one thing that's
really amazing to me that is the shocker
of all development theory that will that
blows me away and I don't have the
answer here is India a really poor
country big labor market and all of a
sudden this software complex emerges in
Bangor but that has never happened
before in development that you've got
them up one of the most backward
countries that somehow got this
continent it's not Seattle or it's not
San Francisco in bangalore does a lot of
Road things but sure enough they're
developed with inside of India a
technological competence and I think the
reason was they spent on higher
education in that area so I think
there's a lot of things we can think
about with regard to development which
challenges old and existing models I
think the thing that happened in Ireland
is fascinating but i do think as these
countries develop they're going to have
to figure out a way to transition from
mass labor markets low-wage offshore
cheap production and transition
themselves to make it in incremental
investments in their creative capital
and hope now the one other thing I want
to say I'm going to challenge the United
States by my country I talked about how
wonderful it was that we could attract
the best and the brightest from around
the world I said how great it was for
our economy that we've attracted great
Asians and Indians and European
entrepreneurs
but think about what we're doing for
more than a millisecond we run down our
own education system we run down our
elementary and secondary schools we make
substandard investments in them and what
do we say to fill the talent gap we're
going to import the best and the
brightest from the poorest countries in
the world what we have done is allow the
poorest countries in the world to
subsidize our substandard educational
system that's horrible I mean that's
just terrible and I understand that we
want to give and we don't want to shut
the board as we want these people to
come and enjoy the opportunities but as
a citizen of the world we've got to
figure out a way to be I think this is
much more than taking their raw
materials taking be able to attract the
best and the brightest and using the
poorest countries in the world to
subsidize our own deficiencies I think
it's tragic that's something that I
would encourage you guys to win dress in
all of us to think about it because if
we don't it may come around back and
bite us raining or disagreeing with some
of your some of your thinking and
theories than that i live in knoxville
tennessee and started a mutual fund
company there there's not any mutual
funds in the area and all of these
Tennessee and so with our ability to use
the internet to go places we don't have
to be in manhattan to be in that
business though what's your thinking in
that area i think i think the internet
enables lots of transactions to occur
and lots of things to be done remotely
but where there needs to be a
concentration of talent whether that be
in software development or biotechnology
artistic and creative communities that's
when you see the need for physical
proximity now clearly what's happening
in our society is not one way or the
other our society is both decentralizing
and centralizing together we're both
developing stronger nodes and we're
making things more just I've been very
involved in the process to rebuild lower
Manhattan and one of the arguments on
the table one of the arguments I'm
advocating is that the financial markets
are inexorably decentralizing that lower
Manhattan will never become the kind of
financial center at once was for all the
reasons you said what lower Manhattan
can become though is a creative Center I
don't know if it's the example of Disney
I don't know if it sees the ample of
Michael Bloomberg
combining technology with finance I
don't know if it's a link to Soho and
tying arts and graphic designs to
finance but I do know that some parts of
our capitalist economy are decentralized
where other ones are coming together and
and that's a big lacunae it's a big
lacunae but in some places importantly
and in some industries this
concentration is really important I
think we have time for two more
questions so you and you and then let's
wrap it I guess number five on your list
in the tank and great pride and Jimi
Hendrix museum Jimi Hendrix was a
satellite and you know lots of
creativity a lot of good success stories
of entrepreneurship but we just suffered
a you know a major loss with Boeing
leaving to Chicago so I'm wondering
that's sort of as I'm hearing kind of
goes against your theory of you know
Carly Fiorina and people moving where
the people are based on your ranking so
I'm wondering how how you view that
what's here what's your read on why
Boeing moved I'm not stuck at any one
involving about this what I do see
though is happening in the Seattle
economy is it's transitioning very
rapidly from a Boeing driven economy to
a broadly creative economy and the whole
area where boeing is as you know is
being transformed from an older
manufacturing area to whatever it is
becoming creative kind of an area I
think there's a lot of reasons behind
Boeing's move I don't want to go into
them here which are not just selecting
one place over another in Chicago's
defense I will say I will say this all
those Chicago ranks on what lower than
seattle on my creativity index it's
about in the top 15 somewhere in my
focus groups and interviews with young
people chicago consistently made the top
five cities now as an East Coaster that
kind of surprised me Chicago was never a
city that high on my radar screen but
something that's happened in Chicago has
made it an exciting City and a place
where you can attract town I think the
Boeing decision was made on a whole set
of other forces including what their
plans for Seattle are right at including
the globalization of the aircraft
business at Seattle probably will not be
home
to as much of a share of the boeing
business and it was much more infant
ages to be somewhere else as that
occurred but but that those are a whole
bunch of hypotheses that I can't confirm
one more I think one more question and
then we'll even problem I could talk
after we're done we're involved in
construction and no one wants to go
swing a hammer anymore and these kids
are graduating high school and you want
to become hair cutters and if you're
absolutely right how do i as an
entrepreneur who is paying wants to pay
for this privileged class again maintain
my business when in a sense I'm maybe
putting myself out of business as well i
think that one great thing about this
country particularly in the low skilled
businesses look at the influx of
immigrants like my grandparents you know
came from Italy and we're willing to be
Mason's in bricklayers and construction
workers I mean one of the great legacies
of this country is that we've been able
to recruit low-skilled low-income
immigrant labor and I think that's one
of the solutions to this problem I don't
know how that affects your particular
business circumstance what surprises me
as I go around this country and I go to
places like arkansas and alabama
Milwaukee and I see these huge new
immigrant populations springing up and
involved both in manufacturing and then
various kinds of construction trades
that heartens me so I would say yeah
Americans are going to be less likely to
want to do these jobs but what we can
benefit from are a whole bunch of new
people new Americans who who would kill
to do these jobs and and and really
where does the entrepreneurial spirit
come from in our nation it comes from
our ability to allow newcomers to
realize their dreams so I'm around if
you want oh by the way my email if you
want to contact me is Florida just like
this state as my mother told me to say
when I smell my name Florida at CMU edu
and thanks very much for listening and
thank you for your great question
Richard Florida is author of the rise of
the creative class it's published by
basic books online at basic books calm
you're watching book TV on c-span 2
created by the cable television industry